Hi. I'm Bleu Knight.
I'm here with Daniel Friedman.
Today is November 8th, 2021
for a guest stream with Adam Safron.
Adam, please take it away.
Bleu. Daniel Hi, everyone.
It's good to be talking with you today.
And I guess we're here to talk
about psychedelics and the five issue
and related systems and active inference.
And so I'll describe some recent work
on this
and looking forward
to talking about it with you.
So let me get my screen
sharing on
coming to.
Excellent.
So, um, I'm using my
active inference
workshop slides as a base
and I'll go through those
with a little bit slower than I did.
The 10 minutes I had there.
And then we'll take it from
there and talk it out. So
this is
part of an ongoing project to both try
to understand
the mechanisms of psychedelics,
but also the impacted neurotransmitter
modulator systems and the roles
they would have in an active inference
and their potential significance for
their use as machine
learning parameters, potentially.
And so when it comes to psychedelics,
much of the attention has been on the
five to a system
and that's a lot of evidence indicates
that it mediates the effects.
Barely any work has been done in machine
learning on this
and it has been worked on
in active inference.
And I'm going to introduce some
a compatible but slightly different take
on the potential significances
of these systems.
So within machine learning,
a good amount of work end
with an act of inference has been done
on the potential roles
of dopamine as a parameter
encoding the
confidence one might have with respect
to policy selection,
Diane and others have suggested
that serotonin can act with an impotency
of dopamine based on a variety of lines
of evidence from neurophysiology.
And so some work has also been done
in introducing a complementary
uncertainty parameter
in the form of serotonin.
This opponent
C can be thought of almost a yin yang,
like with dopamine being more of the yang
and serotonin being more of the yin
dopamine in general,
indicating the neuroscience,
literature, literatures,
incentive salience, confidence,
and if excessive potentially impulsivity,
serotonin
would be an opponent C
or an or complementarity
would indicate the satisfaction,
desires, states of uncertainty
and potentially a factor
helping to allow for patience
rather than impulsivity
with respect to policy selection.
So very little
work, though, has been done in machine
learning on five issue to A
and also in terms of active inference
in terms of actually modeling
the five issue to a system as an active
inference parameter work is probably
going to begin soon in this direction,
largely informed by the Rebus paradigm,
which we'll talk about soon.
But go back to the fundamentals
of these systems.
The work that's been done
so far with the serotonin system
can be thought of more
as relating to the one system.
This would be in contrast
to the higher thresholds.
I believe it's a
5 to 1 ratio of sensitivity
for the receptor of the two system.
So when serotonin, both of these
both of so
five is serotonin and you have some,
I think 14, maybe 17 classes of receptors
depending on how you count them.
But, you know, so I want to talk about
all of them, maybe eventually, but
it seems that
we might be able to go a fair ways focus
in terms of understanding
their significance,
focusing on a few classes
and sort of working our way forward
with the additional receptors,
maybe having a common significance
to the other ones,
but just because they're located in
different parts of the brain
is a common and significance.
But functionally,
you need them to do different things
if located in different places
into more detail.
So but the one AI system
is shown to in
general have more inhibitory effects on
the signaling of pyramidal neurons,
while the five AC to a system tends
to be more excitatory, carhart-harris
and nut have suggested
that these both in a face of challenge,
would be responses to challenge.
But the one aim might be something
more like an active or a passive coping
response being more still,
patients stop
and think as opposed to the to a system
which might be more of an active
coping response in the face of challenge,
something more imaginative
and potentially creative. So
let's let's keep going.
So going back to dopamine versus
serotonin.
Serotonin in general, not focusing
necessarily on one avers is to say
there seems to be some evidence
suggesting that dopamine
will push you or actually a good amount,
that dopamine tends to push
the organism towards
more externally focused attention
in terms of helping
to increase the gain on more exterior
supportive and salience networks
for externally focused attention.
So I think she, in contrast,
seems to be up regulating
the default mode
and more internally focused attention.
So that's another interesting
difference.
But to come to the two,
so these receptors, as I mentioned
before, they tend to have
high thresholds
for activation by serotonin
one, they will be modulating
mood as your sirtuin levels
are going up and down, you might get
this sort of gentle adjustment,
but to a it's going to take more
to really get those systems going.
In fact,
some of their activity might be modulated
by things other than serotonin.
So there's evidence
that things like carbon dioxide,
maybe blood acidity in general
is changing their activity.
And maybe the endogenous DMT system,
which we could talk about later. So
psychedelics tend to come in
two classes, one
or class of psychedelics.
One would be based
on the structure, structure of trip
to being the precursor of serotonin.
And the other would be based
on the structure of
funnel, ethyl amine
precursor of catch it.
All elements of both of these
seem to be active at the five issue
to a system which
variety of lines of evidence
have been shown to mediate
the effects of psychedelics
to a very substantial degree.
So in the
machine learning type work,
I've been collaborating with JIRA
six by he to try to reverse engineer
these different neuro modulators
as machine learning parameters.
And so we've been using an architecture
which has elements of metaphors,
world models and dangerous dreamer
to interpret of five
signaling as potentially being a
as the different classes of receptors,
as parameters for imaginative
planning or an active inference
terms, a sophisticated inference.
So with
respect to all models,
you'll see as it's working, it's working.
So an enhancement.
Hoover's architecture,
they'll use these auto encoders
to take these different frames.
This is in a Doom game.
They'll compress them into a lower
dimensional latent space,
and then they will unpack these
and through this
training of the auto encoder
to learn how to reconstitute
these frames, you get this low dimension
source of low
dimensional vectors and latent space
which can be used for training and
with much better computational efficiency
and some learning properties.
When you don't have to go
all the way back to pixel space
where things can get messy
and you don't know what's causing what.
If you work with this latent space,
you can come out
substantially ahead in terms of training.
And so
you have this variational on encoder,
which is learning how to compress scenes.
So this is one aspect of or compress
the observations.
You then feed this latent space,
compressed vectors
into this recurrent network
which learns to predict
the state transitions,
shove this into a much lower
dimensional controller,
which they trained
with evolutionary strategies,
and then use this for policy selection,
generating new observation
and the standard
sort of reinforcement learning paradigm.
The interesting
thing about this is
they could also be run offline.
So you're able to take these
and take the outputs
and feed it right back in
and you can do imaginative roles.
So you can use this for planning
or for having the agent train
in this imagination.
And so this would be an example
I believe left would be,
but seen in the left would be
the compressed latent space
and then the right would be the agent.
Actually, I think the left is
what was actually seen.
This is pixel space and the right is the
the emergence of latent space.
So it tends to be you're not really
seeing it here, but it tense these
imagine trainings like imagination
relative to perception or sensation.
It's less
fidelity, but you can still use it
for the sake of planning and learning.
But one issue is that
these agents can do
a kind of self adversarial tack
when they're training their imagination.
So if the temperature of the uncertainty
isn't high enough,
they can basically come up
with these sort of fantasies
of easy environments
where they are just winning,
but then this doesn't
transfer to the real world.
And so then by introducing
a temperature parameter
to increase the uncertainty
of your imaginative rollouts,
this allows for better
training back to the real world.
And so this,
I've been suggesting,
is essentially one interpretation
of the 541 system.
The is increasing the temperature
putting the organism
basically instead of dopamine
would be your confidence go forth and act
serotonin acting on the one SS would say
we're not so confident, stop and think
or imagine, don't act right away,
but let's let's think this out
or let's imaginatively plan this out.
Look a little bit in our mind's eye
before we leave the two.
It seems like it's almost like a hybrid
of the one A and opening
where it's like, okay, imagine more,
but it's not necessarily doing
so under a state of uncertainty
within these imaginative worlds,
things are appearing more vivid.
But where the gap between imagination
and reality seems to be narrowing
and the ideas of
if you're thinking back to like
passive versus active coping,
so you're uncertain.
Let's say the one system is in the mix.
Now you're okay.
I'm not going to overtly act and I stop
and think I'm to reduce the gain on the
expected free energy or the expected
value of pursuing a policy.
Right now
patients.
But if the two I gets in the mix,
it's going to tend to be more active.
You're going to be imagining,
but you're going to be
more likely to act on these imaginings
because you're
they're more compelling, more vivid.
So now we're coming back to psychedelics.
I want to lay out this foundation
because the whole way through the method
is basically a kind of Marion
neuro phenomenology,
trying to understand the mind
at computational functional algorithmic
and implementation levels of analysis,
and then mapping this on to
rich descriptions of experience,
subjective experience of mapping
standard, the cognitive science
multilevel start to phenomenology.
And so the machine learning
is part of pulling off this mapping.
We can use our active
inference as part of that. So
to rehearse the basics of
Rebus, but I might come across a writer
checking in.
Okay, so relax.
Police under psychedelics.
This, I'd say, might be
the dominant paradigm for understanding
the significance of the five
C to a system
in creating the effects of psychedelics
under a predictive processing paradigm.
So according to Rebus, you will get
I don't think I have to rehearse
predictive coding here, but very briefly,
the idea is you have a hierarchy
where of predictions,
where you are passing your priors
or your prediction errors
down the hierarchy,
back towards primary modalities
where the observations are coming in
and then you're passing
prediction errors upwards.
And this coding scheme is efficient,
especially if the events that you're
tracking or trying to model are clocking
slower to the internal state.
So something like telecommunications,
if all you have to do is transmit
what's different between the frames
and it's not a 24 hertz seems to be
what TV was back in the day, but most of
the pixels are largely the same frame.
The frame and all you do is you show
what's it's difference.
You get this energy savings and you're
dealing with an organ as hungry
as a brain, 2 to 3% of your body
mass, 20% of the budgets of that.
That savings could be substantial.
And in a natural world of the quick
and the dead
natural selection
might have picked such a thing.
So within creative coding,
the predictions
are thought to be encoded by these.
So if you think of cortex, as
Jeff Hawkins says, it's roughly
a dinner napkin and thickness and extent
that's been crumpled up
and shoved into your head.
Cortex
has these different layers, roughly six.
And so
and this is distinct from like levels of
a hierarchy, but the cortex, the sheet,
if you go like across the napkin,
there's these layers about six
and depending on where you are,
they're more or less distinct.
But the L5 or the deep pyramidal neurons,
these are ones that will leave cortex,
do things like form loops with thalamus,
the stratum,
cerebellum, spine and
that's what will is thought
to encode your predictions.
These L5 deep, primal neurons,
not deep in terms of a deep belief
hierarchy, but deep in terms of relative
to the cortical surface.
More in there
and within the napkin,
the prediction errors
are thought to be encoded
by the superficial pyramidal neurons.
Layers two three.
So L five is forming these big
synchronous complexes with the thalamus
probably not the only way
it does the predictions, but this will be
aggregating information
from multiple different places,
giving you and because you're able
to get a lot of different
causes brought together, it's
going to be a good source of priors.
It's going to be good source
of your expectation and your modeling.
And then you use this to try to suppress
the ascending stream of prediction
errors along this superficial layer
two or three.
You can go into layer later
if that's useful,
but the idea is that
with under psychedelics
you take l five pyramidal
neurons, these excitatory neurons,
and you excite them so much with 5 to 8
stimulation that they fall out of sync
with each other.
And it's,
it's a kind of paradoxical effect,
but when they fire too
readily, they don't coordinate any more
in establishing a synchronous rhythm.
And because of this,
they're actually paradoxically relaxing.
The priors become less precise.
The belief or free energy
landscape becomes flatter.
And so the idea is,
with your expectations being less,
more information from the periphery
is capable of penetrating
deeper into the cortical hierarchy,
registering more in consciousness,
and impacting learning and updating
to a potentially greater degree.
And so this is a model of the much
of the phenomenology of psychedelics,
as well as their mechanism of
therapeutic action for helping people to
Pollan would say,
like how to change your mind,
helping you to change
and change your mind to update.
And so
I think Rebus is largely correct,
but I've been introducing
a potential refinement of it
in something I call Albus, which includes
in addition to Rebus effects,
something I call service effects
or strengthened beliefs.
And so the idea is that
although you might not get exactly this
D synchronization effect
along the whole dose response curve of 5G
to a agonism of
or stimulation of the 5st to a receptor,
whether this might be the case
of what you would expect
from very high levels of agonism
the really strong excitation.
But let's say we increase the gain like
just a little bit or a moderate amount.
I suggest it's not at all
obvious that this would cause
the energy landscape to flatten.
This would not cause them necessarily
to fall out of sync with each other.
In fact, they might be able to sync up
even more powerfully
if you just increase it
a little bit or moderately.
We don't actually know.
This might vary
from organism to organism,
but the idea is we might need different
regimes, different accounts,
depending on where we are,
with what level of stimulation before
we would expect to see the kind
of paradoxical synchronization
or potentially more straightforward
enhanced synchronous ability
of the.
Yeah, so,
so bringing back to predictive coding.
So here, if you're going to try
to illustrate this,
the purple would be your deep
pyramidal neurons
supposedly encoding the erm
that are thought to encode your beliefs.
And then up top
you have the white circles.
This would be your superficial pyramidal
neurons,
the upper part of the layer
and this would be encoding
your prediction areas
that you're passing upwards.
And so you're seeing these I'm
illustrating the synchronous complexes
by these red swaths, the predictions
going downwards of these red arrows.
And then I'm depicting basically
the prediction errors as these gray swaps
and black arrows.
So within predictive coding,
there's been significance
assigned to different EEG
and frequency bands
as potentially corresponding more or less
to predictions or prediction errors.
More specifically, the slower rhythms
like alpha and beta, where alpha is
maybe roughly 8 to 12 times
a second, beta
is maybe 13 to 30 times
a second that these slower rhythms
would be the ones encoding
your predictions passed downwards,
but that your prediction errors
might be more likely to be encoded by
gamma frequencies,
you know, anywhere from 40 to 120
and even higher oscillations per second.
So within this part of the reason
that this might make some intuitive sense
is if you're thinking of the formation
of a synchronous
complex of neural activity that
faster would be
smaller and slower would be bigger
or more inclusive, more integrative.
This might make some intuitive sense
if you're thinking of, okay,
so you're trying to get this agreement,
this negotiation of a common rhythm
of a bunch of signaling units.
If you're having more units
spread over a bigger
distance, you're trying to get them
to go coming to agreement.
This might necessarily
have to be a slower process,
but if you're, let's say,
like quantifying prediction
or generally like a little packet
of like a local agreement that you're
passing upwards, well, that you could
potentially clock a lot quicker. So
that's the basic idea there.
So if you were to look at Rebus,
it would look something like you see the
the right bottom,
the swath of red
is more restricted in scope
and the arrows are a little bit smaller.
And so this is idea of
you've relaxed your beliefs.
This is if you get this paradoxical
D synchronization, but
and so once you have this
you're seeing less of these prediction
areas are being inhibited
by this descending stream of predictions
and they're able to make their way
in more deeper into the hierarchy.
And this would be showing very obviously,
the brain is not just one
singular hierarchy, but it's a hierarchy.
Multiple intersecting hierarchies,
corresponding to each of your modalities,
all brought together,
stitched together into a turkey
up top
would be illustrating a seabus effect.
And so the swath is bigger and the of
the arrows are also darker and bigger.
And that's and more prediction
errors are being inhibited.
There's an additional factor,
which is 542
A receptors are also found
on the inhibitor interneurons of layers.
Two three And so in theory
and there's some evidence,
I believe, that suggests this
this would correspond to a default
reduction in the gain on the ascending
stream of prediction areas, or
you would say an active inference speak
less precision weighting of the precision
of the prediction errors.
And so they have less of a contribution
of the Bayesian
updating that's happening
at each level of this belief hierarchy.
And so that's illustrated by a slightly
if this is
yeah, the the ground,
the arrows are a little bit smaller.
So the idea here
with a CBC effect would be not only might
you have stronger beliefs,
but these beliefs might be further
shielded from contradiction
by inconsistent sense data.
I think this potentially provides
a fairly parsimonious account
of some of the conditions under
which you get certain perceptual
alterations of a hallucinatory variety.
So for instance, people will
sometimes report hallucinations
in sensory deprivation tanks.
They'll sometimes a
I think it's called a Charles
Binney syndrome, where as you search,
let's say go blind or deaf, you'll start
to get like auditory or hallucinations
within the modality as you lose
input from the external world.
This also
you could think of at a higher level.
I don't know if this works,
but you can think of
potentially delusions in a similar way
a belief which is overly strong
and resistant to updating
from potentially contradictory
and potentially correct sense data.
So in theory,
for talking about serious effects,
you might have a single parsimonious
account
for both hallucinations and delusions.
That's
incorporating a little bit
more of the neuroanatomy.
That being said, I'm not saying at all
the rebus is incorrect.
I actually think it's
probably very correct and
maybe crucially important for explaining
some of the really powerful changes
that people observe of psychedelics
as a therapeutic intervention.
So again, to little more details here.
And so here you are with me
still the cash call.
So I mentioned a header of your earlier.
So I've taken these predictive
coding hierarchies here
and I'm just illustrating them
as these triangles.
And so here would be, let's say your
so I think in this
framework of Albus, I'm suggesting
we need to even in addition
to including things like seabus effects,
I think we're going to
need to take on things like
basically consciousness and
higher order consciousness to actually
really adequately explain what we mean
by relaxed or strengthened beliefs
and what actually is happening
with these different door modulators
and maybe attempts at creating analogs.
So here, you know, up top
would be similar sensation
to the right would be in your vision
and then you're hearing
and we're going to try
to bring all these things together.
And so if you're thinking
of some sort of hierarchy
here,
you might have a small beta complexes.
You can think of each of these
as like a small modeling effort
and a small belief over whatever's
in the scope of this synchronous complex,
where the idea being that
when you synchronize neurons,
this allows them to be aligned
in their activity in time such that
their signals can sum and be integrated
rather than decay.
And so this would allow you
to have potentially a joint belief over
whatever is in the scope
of a synchronous complex.
Pascal Freeze calls this communication
through coherence.
And for reference for this idea of like
an inverse hierarchy of size and speed,
but sharky would be a good reference
for that, I'd say.
So here we are on the left.
The beginnings of modeling of
increased hierarchical depth
with small fast
beta complexes, the extraction of things
like line segments, and maybe
basic contours and vision, basic
patterns within sound, within touch.
But then let's say we nest these within
maybe,
maybe slower, broad
or more encompassing data.
We can have more hierarchical structure
for our modeling effort.
And so here
you might start to get the beginnings
of things like objects
as you bring together
these different features,
the beginnings of things like objects
with respect to touch your rather
your own body in relation to those
the beginnings of things
like meaningful sounds.
And so then let's say
we bring all the modalities together.
Now we let them cross talking
about multimodal representation
that you've organized according to
a coherent perspectival reference frame.
Well, now
you might get the beginning of something
like phenomenology or experience.
And so here there's a blue swath
corresponding to alpha frequencies.
Here,
where I'm at alpha
frequencies that would roughly be it
looks like the size that you would need.
So 8 to 12 times
a second of a frequency of updating or
or sampling or estimation
that this would be big enough
to get you the entire sensorium
all brought together, bringing together
that the different hierarchies
into a hierarchy.
Alpha has some additional significance
in that it has particularly concentrated
sources of alpha power
from midline structures.
And I take this as being important,
because if you look at something
like the posterior midline,
we look at, let's say the posterior
single cortex, which is heavily
implicated in the psychedelic and also
the meditation research literatures.
When alpha goes down,
there seems to be some associated
with phenomena such as ego dissolution.
But the idea that
Alpha might be important for coherent,
egocentric perspective in addition
to bringing together your consortium
for this mutual information,
these midline structures, in particular
the posterior cingulate,
there's this whole idea
of the pipette circuit where it's this
core circuit for emotional memory
that would roughly go, Mama,
Natalie bodies around the brainstem.
It goes up through the mammalia
for an track.
I think anterior lateral flank nucleus
goes through the signaling bundle poster
singular into the the campus up
through the fawning specs memo about it.
Don't worry about those details.
The important thing about this is
this was interpreted
by actually I said papers.
I think it's paper.
But it was interpreted by tapes
when he was etching out these sources
of epilepsy from discharge
as his core circuit for emotional memory.
And part of the reason
that and so the importance of this
is the memory bodies are receiving
stretch
receptor information from the neck
and so this is going to be
potentially important
for knowing where your head's pointing,
especially for talking about like
this will be important for us
and maybe even more
so if we're talking about
like our inner road or or whatever that,
you know, where your head's pointing
is going to really help
for bringing coherence
to explaining your sensorium.
Also at the Islamic relay,
you're also getting
inputs from the vestibular
apparatus of the inner ear.
And so this is giving you
to your pitch and role.
And so not only do you have
your entire system, all the information
at these posterior midline structures
before they funnel into the hippocampus
as a source of new memory.
Not only do you have the entire sensory
and brought together,
you're on top of it all.
In network terms.
But you have the information
you would need to organize it
by your egocentric perspective.
And so this yeah.
So we've got
predictive coding. We covered
sea bass effects, readings effects.
And now I'm introducing like
a basic model of perceptual synthesis
where we have something
of a Cartesian theater here, enabled by
the ability of slow
rhythms of a large enough extent
to bring together the right
kinds of information you would need to
basically create a coherent
world model.
So we all would be similar. Okay.
So in this preprint,
I describe how we can maybe
think of with respect to either sensation
or imagination, different combinations
of rebus and seabus effects happening
potentially corresponding
to different levels of stimulation
of these receptor classes of the phobias
you two are in particular, by the way,
I think 5ht to five t
to see that's going to
that's one to watch for.
It might even be like
almost more strictly rebus in its nature,
but that's something to talk about later.
So for sensation on the left here,
this would be there's a person of nature
and they're having an interaction
with a tree.
And then on the right here
would be a similar thing.
But this is imagination.
Maybe with your eyes closed, maybe not.
But this is in here.
You're imagining yourself
interacting with the tree.
Now, you know,
imagination doesn't
need to be in a third person,
but I'm just taking advantage of the fact
that we're talking.
Like if you are to think of yourself
in a third person,
if you're going to move from this,
was it the,
as James called it,
like from the eye to the me
to this objectified selfhood,
that part is going to require
imagination.
You can imagine yourself in the first person, but the third person point of view,
you're going to require imagination.
I guess that or a mirror
or a good set up of mirrors.
Maybe you could do it that way.
Some actually might not.
That might be non-trivial,
but on the left here,
so the top we have, let's say, unaltered,
if such a thing ever exists,
we're always altered in some ways.
We're always on some
you know, our brain
stems from a cookie is always dripping
some combination of drugs to us.
It's just sometimes
it's a very different regime.
And, you know, we say it's altered,
but there is no like singular baseline.
You know, we
who knows how much we both very
as individuals and across individuals
along these lines.
But so as we move down,
let's say we were talking about
a reader's effect
and let's say
you were getting a rebus effect
with sensation.
So in theory, if your perception
is entailed by the predictions,
then it could be the case
that things might seem less vivid to you.
It may not be the case
that your perception is more vivid.
I know I don't know if I would say this
is strictly entailed by the Rebus model,
but that's one thing you might think
potentially if these slow rhythms,
if some of these are actually entail
your conscious experience,
if these are reduced in their coherence
and their power, in theory, you might get
a diminution of perceptual vividness.
However, in a of US interpretation,
things might appear more vivid,
not necessarily more vertical,
but more vivid.
And so it seems like
a Rebus interpretation
would say that things might be
more detailed, more accurate,
more richly textured, with
more faithful correspondences
to the external world.
When you're perceiving
but potentially less vivid,
that causes a strict entitlement.
But that seems like one suggestion
under a sea misinterpretation.
This would be
more vivid,
but not necessarily more precise.
It actually might be a little bit
smoothed over like like an auto
tuning or a filtering, but also though
more compelling potentially.
And so this in theory,
though, would be the phenomenology
of microdosing in theory.
And so
when I get into
and so I try to illustrate this
with a brain or, you know, bigger
or smaller synchronous complexes here.
So Albus there as well,
we could have an admixture.
It's not just one set of beliefs,
but we have a hierarchy of beliefs
and in fact a hierarchy.
So maybe the alpha starts to get
pulled back and that loses coherence.
That seems to be one of the strongest
associations in the psychedelic
meditation literature
is this alpha is what people emphasizes
some of these ego d centering
or dissolving effects,
but maybe beta stays the same
or even increases in power.
And so under a rebus model, for instance,
the idea would be that, you know, things
like Alpha
go down in power, but things like
the particular smaller beliefs,
they can come together
in different ways, in different sort
of creative combinations.
And so you might get something
like synesthesia with psychedelics
as like a creative recombination
of things under this more anarchic state.
Once you took the alpha self ruler
and you reduced its
tyrannical grip over your perception
and so this more free flowing perception,
you get all sorts of different creative
combinations in consciousness.
And so yeah, so that's
one thing is trying to basically map
different combinations of
Rebus
or C base effects that you might expect
under different doses with respect
to either sensation or imagination.
So really digging into the phenomenology
and using psychedelics as an opportunity
actually in a way to indirectly test
models of consciousness.
But also if we're going to explain
what these substances,
powerful substances, are doing,
we really actually need to take
some of these questions head
on, maybe even the heart problem.
So some of the more so in this preprint
I also
are getting into.
Okay, well, what do we mean by beliefs?
What kind of beliefs
are we talking about?
And so so
one kind of beliefs would be so here
you might have the beliefs
with active inference in the free energy
principles, beliefs
the whole way through which beliefs.
And so
Rebus is saying what's specifically
being is being relaxed
is your deeper beliefs,
your internal working
models, the higher level beliefs
corresponding to things like selfhood
and its relation to the world, things
like autobiographical and narrative self.
And these are the things
that are losing their grip and,
and within Rebus I don't want to like
there is room for specifics
some of the ways it's discussed
where it's not just across the board,
all the slow rhythms are going down.
The idea of my maybe
I've heard
it discussed differently
and so you might get,
you know, an indirect strengthening
as you remove
these slower, integrative
and potentially suppressive processes.
But in terms of types of beliefs,
if we're going to be
talking about cognition or
if we're talking about something
as highfalutin as the self
now we might want to see like
what kind of self are we talking about?
Like we're talking about
like a minimal embodied self,
or are we talking about an extended self?
And even those
like there's all sorts of big questions
like what goes into the minimal
embodied self in
house relating to the extended self
and how many
if there's different kinds of votes.
And so if we're talking
about the construction of self
in its relation
to the world and objectified self or the
that the ego, the the self as construed
over time and across
circumstances, we're going to need
a fairly rich account of cognition.
And so here I'm basically
providing an account
of sophisticated affective of inference
or imaginative
planning and policy selection
as orchestrated by the hippocampus
and into renal system.
And so this is drawing on
some of the work I'm doing with Tim
verbally and others.
I'm trying to decipher that system.
But basically, you know, you seem to have
so here,
you know, hippocampus can be thought of
in a way
as the top of the cortical rhetoric
when the prediction
errors are not proved.
So you as the pictures are percolating
upwards, being contradicted
or stopped by predictions,
you stop them as low as you can,
as close to the modalities as you can.
That's the maximum savings,
and that's what you would expect with
the maximally efficient
prediction and learning.
But if you can't predict a pattern,
if nothing, that the genuinely novel
that makes its way all the way up
the hierarchy into the hippocampus
is this prediction error
storage place of last resort.
And you this
then can be stitched together
to create memory
and specifically with hippocampal
and then to run a system seems to do
is it encodes this sequence memory
it has multiple
functions but one of the ways in which
one of its core functions
seems to be the encoding
of trajectories of the overall
organismic system through time and space.
And so if you look at the work of people
like Redish, you'll actually see,
for instance, as this
rodent is in a maze,
figure out where it's going to go.
You'll see these sweeps of activity
within the hippocampus can play out
in different directions across these
place fields or this mapping of space.
And then the organism will take
like one branch for another of these
potential sweeps of predictive activity.
And so probably don't
want to get in descriptively.
I have an account of like the anterior
versus the post.
Your hippocampus
can be qualitatively different
where the answer hippocampus seems to be
the one that's more predictive.
Giving you these sweeps, giving you
things like counterfactual processing,
the anterior seems to be more closely
coupling with the posterior sensorium
and would be more important
for more specific episodic encoding
and maybe more faithful
episodic remembering.
And so the idea is
you have these little hexagons
which corresponds to mapping of space,
these hippocampal place fields,
where is the organism
within some sort of space?
And then they're playing out
in some trajectory.
And so now along this trajectory,
it is you're having the prediction errors
from the cortical generative model,
which can basically by pointing back
to cortex can unpacked unpack
at every point in space
the experience you
would expect for that
particular temporal spatial trajectory.
And this would be an account of
episodic memory and episodic imagination
or the stream of consciousness,
if you will.
Okay, so here we are.
And I think this is the last thing
I'll look.
Yeah.
So here we are.
These trajectories being played out
and different experiences being entailed
at each point as it plays out
and they have a given length,
it seems that there's a extent of this.
I think James called it
the species present
or the idea there's like a thickness
of the moment we find ourselves in or
this might be a somewhat different idea
but there's there seems to be 3 seconds
is seems to be roughly
the upper bound of what we would call
a given extended
moment of experience element,
I think called like
the remembered present.
Or there's a little bit of like
a prediction in a post section and you're
moving back and forth in this sliding
window frame of experience.
And so one interpretation.
And so we don't hear as you're doing
these different episodic
rememberings and imaginings,
that one thing
that the 552 system might do is
both increase the vividness of what
you're imagining or perceiving as you go,
but also allowing you
to have more extended
rollouts before you have to reset
where it seems like a roughly 3 seconds
might be the upper upper bound.
And so
basically have within the pre-print this
this comic description is neuro
phenomenological comic
where as you're increasing
the dose, imagination
is getting closer to perception
and you're
getting a longer one way to work with
for this extended present moment
within which you are planning
and learning and making sense of things.
And so it gets a little bit bigger
with the micro dose,
a little bit bigger
with this threshold dose,
and even more over the years,
you know, when you started out,
you're just like kind of moving
through the world.
I'm kind of awake and kind of conscious,
I guess.
And then it's like I am like
the things are crisper
and a little bit more creative, like,
and not that much.
Here is, but more crisper.
This would be
something like kind of like a some dose,
like a programmer in Silicon Valley,
like Microdosing is very popular.
It doesn't seem that
they're trying to like trip, but they're,
they're almost using it like like
like a little bit of a, a stimulant
trying to like increase absorption
with whatever they're doing.
And so then, so as we move through,
you increase the dose more.
And now it's even more vivid
and more creative, more different.
Imaginings are having access to more
and more is manifesting in mind.
But then after a certain dose, it seemed
what an illustrating is that
basically the the coherence starts to go
and you start to get smaller rollouts.
There are even more of it and they're
more creative, but they're becoming less
clear in terms of the sequencing.
They make less sense with respect
to achieving particular goals.
And so I think something
that I should explain
and we might have to talk it out, but
the underlying this is so, so
these hippocampal resetting events
are occasioned by different things.
One is if I go from one room to a next,
if some sort of like really surprising
thing happens, that's going to trigger
this sharply of ripple activity
and a retailing of space
within which you're doing
your sophisticated inference.
This so something either
so there's there's some evidence that
reward prediction errors and something
really really good happens
that might cause you to basically ramp up
the hippocampal activity, encode that,
you know, generate like aphasia, help
you generate a physic burst of dopamine,
learn it and then keep going.
Or if something really bad happens,
this might be an opportunity to pivot.
What you're doing is not working.
Let's retail, let's try again.
And so
this will be a function of both things,
like what's the normal modulatory tone,
what are those like the circuit
level conditions like maybe directly,
what's your level of five to a simulation
that might influence
how long you get before
you have to reset?
But it could also be explained
at the level of experience itself,
at the level of the expected free energy
changing as a submersion clause.
So as I'm getting creative,
if I get so creative that I'm no longer
making sense of things,
my expected free energy,
if that goes up like that, spikes up.
Because what I just said
is really surprising.
It's novel is experience vividly,
and it's not making a lot of sense.
That might be something
that would occasion this resetting.
And so
idea is a model of basically a
stream of consciousness
or episodic memory,
episodic remembering and imagining,
which becomes a more
coherent, more rich,
more absorbed within this first regime,
and then a second regime
that's more properly psychedelic,
where it's very becomes
extremely creative, so much so that it's
become qualitatively different
to normal experience
and even so much so that like,
for instance, at a certain point
you're not going to be using this
to enhance your job as a programmer.
You'll be doing this on vacation with
trusted others or something like this.
Hopefully
this is not something to take to work at,
you know,
if not megadoses at work hopefully,
or they will not be working there
for very long.
At most workplaces.
And so
yeah, that's basically
and so then coming
looping back around to the beginning,
that is with a deeper understanding
of these systems
that includes some Rebus aspects
and some CBS type aspects.
We might be able to use these
as inspiration
for novel active inference machine
learning parameters.
So potentially you can think of like
getting stuck at like people.
They're living like a life
of quiet aspiration or something.
They've gotten stuck
at some kind of local maxima
and they're looking to change and
they're looking to get a kick out of it.
They're they're not finding
an elegant path
to minimize their expected free energy.
And so if you've found yourself trapped
at this local free energy minima,
you can use psychedelics to turbocharge
your sophisticated affect of inference
enough to maybe find a novel
solution, see
something that you wouldn't otherwise.
And then I guess the final thing
I would like to point to is
in terms of
using psychedelics as a probe on mind,
you might have different interpretations
of what they reveal.
If you're thinking of either a strictly
see the story, a strictly
read a story, or some kind of combination
of the both of them.
And so I'd suggest that, for instance,
you can think of a good amount
of psychedelic phenomenology
as corresponding
to the unmasking of your core priors.
And so things like, let's say fractal,
fractal phenomenology,
that maybe would be
a core perceptual prior
maybe of a partially evolutionary,
partially as a
reliably learnable posterior
or empirical prior
for making sense of the world.
And this would make some sense in that
if you use fractals as you're generating
your predictions, that's a very efficient
basis set because you can
you can do a lot with different
combinations of fractals.
And this is especially going to
be efficient if that's what nature itself
doing.
You're using different combinations
of fractal processes to model the world,
which is largely structured
by different combinations of fractal type
generative processes.
Further things like entity perceptions
is associated
with different psychedelic experiences,
archetypical type experiences.
Those also could be thought of
as the unmasking of core priors.
Essentially strengthened. Core priors
lets you know because would expect
from active inference
that entities is something
the kind of thing you would expect
as a very powerful empirical prior
because that's
how we survive, especially agents
such as us who think
through other minds and we're our primary
niches, largely each other.
And so
whether we're you know,
the details of psychedelics
might actually reveal these foundational,
inductive biases or foundational lessons
in the learning curriculum,
the structure learning, whereby we come
to be the kinds of beings we are,
and that is it for now.
Okay.
Thank you, Adam.
That was super awesome.
I am like particularly overloaded
right now, unlike
my one A receptors, which is like
I just want to imagine and step back
before I ask some questions.
I know Daniel asked a lot.
So I'm going to let him like ground me
a little bit in reality
and have the first job.
I was just writing a bunch of stuff
in the live chat,
so definitely anyone can ask because
you've jumped through many areas.
So if anybody has a question,
they can type it.
But let's take a quick breath, collect
our thoughts and then Bleu
you can ask the first question.
Which I just passed to you to,
like, ground me.
All right. So, so
I guess I'm already here.
All right?
Since I'm already here, I'm going to like
and clearly asked
a whole lot of questions at once
and also like
try not to fangirl out too much
because this line of work is really super
awesome and unifies
the whole lot of my particular interests.
So just really quickly,
what do you think the relationship is,
if any, between inference and memory?
And can we quantify that
through the brain, the brain system,
dopamine, serotonin, like
do you have thoughts on that?
I'm sure you do.
Or do you have thoughts
that you can summarize in, you know,
10 minutes or less?
Yeah. Hmm.
So in terms of memory,
there's a sense in which
it's all like there's a sense in which
within the free energy principle,
max of inference know all like wasn't
all effective causation is inference
and it's all inference
based on different kinds of memory.
So so your belief
every belief is a memory and everything
that happens is a kind of action
as a kind of inference.
But there's another sense, though,
of like memory of the time and the kind
I'm trying to get to
with like the focus on the hippocampal
and to renal system,
this orchestration of the overall
memory system and this encoding
of the general genuinely novel
and these episodes
and these frames of sense making that
this would be
of a more complex
kind of inference and a sophisticated one
specifically where you are
inferring the most plausible
a a rather than so.
So there could be a sense
for, for instance, in which
you might get a fairly
under some circumstances maybe for
like recent things that the aren't like
I don't know what the shelf
life would be, but like the
so some of the
the literature that a couple of weeks
couple months I don't know but like that
actually hippocampal system through
just this chaining of attracting states
lines trajectories
could point back to cortex
and play out something
that's actually like a fair, a decently
faithful but still very biased account,
a reconstruction,
a remembering of what occurred.
But for things that are older, that's
probably not the case.
Even for things that are newer,
there's this constructive.
So it's always constructive
and that it's always a kind of at
every moment
perception is inference. At every moment.
There's a creative aspect of filling in,
but actually like situating yourself
within some sort of causal unfolding
that's going to involve a lot of value
catalyzed policy selection
that's can involve you using constraints
like, well, what kind of being do
I think I am and what's plausible.
And that's going to determine
when you're going down this like
this branching, forking
paths of different possibilities, like
you'll be moving between like or what
might I have done to do this or that?
And you'll be picking plausible accounts
of you partially as you go.
And so some remembering
might be a little bit
like the
naive, like playback one of you playback,
the trajectory.
It's got pointers back to cortex
and then you have this belief hierarchy
and so you give the practioners
back to where things are new
and then it just unpacks itself as a
a good enough
account of what happened to each point
as you went through some trajectory.
And it's a decent semi
faithful player, but
there's also going to be
this other kind of memory, though,
that's that's not faithful at all
and can really deviate
a substantial amount of all where
in hard to distinguish from imagination
and continuous with it.
So like how do you know
if you're remembering something
or imagining
you use these different cues?
One cue
you might use is perceptual vividness.
So you would assume,
like if I remember something going to be
a little bit crisper
and if I just like totally made it up,
the other one might be like
just the plausibility.
Like, yeah, that's like the kind of thing
someone like me would do.
And, but you can get a confused,
maybe a source monitoring error.
And I think that's actually in a way
for psychedelics, both in terms of
if this core process of figuring out
who you are, where you've been,
where you're likely to go
and where you ought to go,
thinking of these pathways as potentially
what it is to
be an agent as revealing ways
that agency and
and different self-consciousness
and selfhood can vary.
But also in terms of this,
I think needs to be broadened in terms
of what we might expect to be impacted
and what we might want to prepare
for in heart and harness
with things like psychedelics.
So for instance,
there might be a very real risk
for phenomena such as false memory.
So if the gap between perceptual
perception and image and imagination
starts to narrow, if your imagination
starts to seem more vivid,
it might become more difficult
to distinguish between a remembering
and an imagining or
yeah, so things of that nature.
So that I think the issue of
what is memory
and its relation to inference
is going to be key for what it is like.
We want to alter and what it is
we maybe don't want to alter
but might accidentally alter when we do
different types of interventions.
So like you played
so perfectly into my follow up
question was like,
how does creativity play into that?
Right?
And like what is maybe
the function of creativity
like I mean, personally,
my autobiographical memory is awful,
but like I have a really strong holds,
like good factual memory
for like all kinds of ridiculous things.
So, so where does creativity play
into that?
Like, memory, perception,
inference like paradigm
and are like the people
that are more creative
or that take more psychedelics?
Like,
do they have a less like accurate memory
or are they more likely to remember
remember things inaccurately
or even like what is inaccuracy?
Sorry, let me just get super meta
because I really fundamentally believe
that perception is different
for all of us.
But like what is written in my bio
textbook?
Less so.
So maybe that's why like I put less
priority on my autobiographical memory
because it's I believe it's functionally
inaccurate, but like whatever.
How many angstroms are between
each subunit of DNA?
That's way more, you know, important.
Right?
I mean, that's
one of
the hardest questions I can think of.
And so then I want to know
what's important, too.
So there's this I'm trying to
I forget the name of the paper.
It's dual constraints model of creativity
that does address like head
on the issue of kinds of creativity
and psychedelics some of that later.
But the
it does seem like, for instance,
there are
I necessary tradeoffs
with respect to different processes
as to whether they allow
for realizing different types of value.
So let's say so with memory
or with creativity,
you might distinguish between divergent
and convergent creativity,
like convergent creativity,
where like you want to hit a particular
target and generate a novel solution
for a particular challenge
or divergent,
where let's say you just want to think
of something new, maybe just
a novelty generator
from which you then might select later
convergence solutions
and a longer process or just as part of
an open ended exploration.
And so
in those different ways,
like, for instance, like you could
get if you just turn up
the heat, the temperature
and you make things more
imprecise and unconstrained,
you might be able to get all sorts
of different combinations.
And this might be a good
like fountain of divergent creativity.
Some of the evidence suggests,
I believe, that
even with the micro dose regime.
So I think
people who are doing like Microdosing,
usually they're looking for things
like enhance conversion, creativity.
I don't think the evidence is great
that that's actually being achieved, but
diversion, creativity might be more
likely to be associated with
psychedelic experience,
proper combinations of things
that just you never would have imagined.
It's not clear.
It's not necessarily even useful
for any particular thing.
It's not hitting
any particular target necessarily.
It might be after the fact.
It might reveal something to you
that you never imagined
that have made all the difference.
Maybe it's like a
just your defense mechanisms in terms
of like your policy selection
as leading into garden paths.
You're seeing some things and not others.
And then it took the blinders off
to reveal something
that you might have missed.
But I'd say that people definitely vary
partially, maybe due to things
like low level parameter tunings,
like different people will vary in terms
of like the natural level of the gain
on these systems, the natural tendencies
for occupying these different regimes.
And so you'd expect that to vary either
through some combination of things best
explained at low levels like, you know,
different levels of neuro modulators.
And some of it would be not well
explained at that level.
It's more just that's the way
the structure learning happened.
That's the way the system bootstrap
itself, different kind of agent
and everything in between.
So one thing that I find to be like
I want to go into is
that humanness in general, us
as a creative species,
that these pathways
might have been important
for allowing us to have be more creative
and being able to combine things
in a broader range of ways
and that this potentially,
you know, unlocked a more flexible type
of cognition,
maybe a greater capacity
for analogical reasoning,
the kinds of things
that might have potentially precipitated
this great leap forward in the birth
of cognitive modernity, where we became
a symbolic species and cultural evolution
came off the ground.
There's an
older idea of mechanical,
the stone ape theory that like there
was actually like a period
where we were in this symbiosis
with mushrooms and we're eating
psilocybin containing mushrooms.
And this actually helped
to get that going.
And I don't think we can rule that out,
but you could also get something
very similar with,
you know, a couple of high
impactful mutations along these pathways
that doesn't involve
a mushroom eating phase.
And so there still might be
really interesting account of actually
the secret of our success
as a species, as a particularly creative
kind of hominid who's able
to bring things together in more
novel, imaginative ways
that could be involved
and being continuous
with the story of psychedelics
and how they work and in the present day.
So that obviously,
you know, I'm extremely interested in
and also though as a source,
you're saying individual difference like,
you know, are there more like to this day
more shamanic
personalities are there, you know,
are there more?
And to what degree can this account
be told at the level of genes
is or epigenetics
or is not well told there one.
Yeah.
So let's share some thoughts on that.
Okay.
So wait, now you just like walked
into this trap that I laid for you, so
I've now got to ask this next question.
So you talked a lot about
psychedelics and sensory deprivation
and now you want to talk about like
our symbiotic relationship with fungi.
And I'm a huge Terence McKenna fan.
So if you've read that cake revival,
which I'm sure you have,
so where do sensory deprivation
in conjunction with psychedelic use,
like where does that fall on this like
perceptual perception
action, mental action,
alpha beta, brainwave,
serotonin, dopamine spectrum.
Like, I just want to know your thoughts.
Sorry, not sorry, but I'm sorry.
So I don't know
if this exactly gets at it,
but it's possible that
this would be rather different.
But like, okay, this is this.
We're really going to go into conjecture
land here, but
so what the book is, it's a recent one
about us is
so that there's like two domestication
books recently about humanness
the so one of them is the goodness
paradox
and us is a self domesticated species.
And there's this other more recent one,
but there is that this
serotonin
pathways,
if depends on which ones you're
talking about to be quite different.
But if they're upregulated, let's say
have a one variety, you could think of
that as being more conducive to something
like a domesticated phenotype.
So if your dopamine is higher and you're
you're having
your spec, you're more confident
in your policy
selection, then
that might also cause you
to be somewhat impulsive
and that might make you not necessarily
be able to
discount utility enough, hold back,
think things through a bit more, and
if the dopamine is too high,
you might get less cooperatively
if it's
and so you can think of the serotonin
to the patients
that it's the one in particular as being
of a domesticated variety.
And things might appear, for instance,
less vivid, perceptually
and imaginatively, in theory alone,
if we're just talking
about those pathways.
And the two way, you know, is
by the for all this, there's so much
we don't know.
So so much of this is conjecture.
But the two, A, does
seem to have a little bit
more of a dopaminergic
character to it. And
the and
actually, it seems like that
pathway evolved roughly
around the time of the Cambrian Explosion
around with the advent of Jaws in
the context of predator prey arms races.
And so that might be consistent
with like a dopaminergic significance.
So this like temporarily increasing
your confidence in your past selection,
like turbocharging your action selection
a bit so you can go out and get the goal
of either
getting your lunch
or avoiding becoming lunch.
And so
let's say you're moving into
greater gain on imagination.
Let's say we're thinking serotonin
either of the one or two is doing this.
This then might compete with more
externally focused perception sensation.
And so you're imagining more,
but because your mind's eyes occupied
more with your imaginings,
you might be attending to the details
of the environment a little bit less.
And so
a species or an individual
who might have the gain for whatever
reason, higher on these pathways,
you might call this
a little bit more shamanic
or maybe a little bit further on,
like a schizophrenia type spectrum
might be perceiving the world
slightly less faithfully, but
their imagination is now freed up to be
more freewheeling and more creative.
And this is allowing for
different things
to come into being so very speculative.
We might think of like Neanderthals
as like less than domesticated
humans, maybe even a little bit
more like autism spectrum,
but like better able
of perceiving the world precisely
and us.
We might have been a little bit
more shamanic, a little bit more,
although we are the Neanderthals
also because we all interbred
and the variant know
the variance within is probably bigger.
It's definitely bigger
than the variance between but of
us and the our ancestors and
us. We might be somewhat somewhat less.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'd say less dopamine.
I know if I say that.
So that's what I got for now.
Thanks, Adam.
Great presentation.
Just want to make two quick notes,
ask some questions from the chat.
So the first is
there's no free lunch with strategy.
So there's dishes
that are just unwinnable
where the phenotype cannot win.
And then there's other niches
where potentially
a broad range of phenotypes
all can proliferate.
So whether or not a given strategy
is successful or under what cases
are a given kind of neuro
modulatory state
is good or bad, by what metric?
There's just no single
free lunch or preference for lunch food.
Then the second point was the complex
gene.
Family Point was very interesting.
And you mentioned some other receptors
in the serotonin receptor family
and there are many receptors,
including ones that don't have nice
clean names like number one
and number two and number three.
So how these 14.
Yeah so how to interpret. These protein.
Investigating function in these massively
interacting and often redundant
like F seven does something that only
when eight is gone, what's the actual
mechanism there?
So here's some questions from the chat.
So first question from a chat
Steven asked
interested in the approximately 3/2
window of conscious awareness
and I mentioned does that trace back
to William James stream of consciousness
awareness and the temporal scale
scales of experience?
I believe so.
So it's kind of like a 3/2
echo is our experience
or what does the 3 seconds represent?
So so the empirically established
phenomenon is there seems to be
stitching things together
into one continuous unfolding.
There seems to be a 3/2 upper bound
within this continuous unfolding.
I believe there is relevance to James.
The species present and Edelman's
remembered present this idea of a kind of
anticipatory prediction
and looking ahead and a post fictive
going back to you're moving back
and forth of your self in this unfolding.
And the speculative part is
I am suggesting that
this might correspond to the, uh,
a hippocampal
and two renal tiling of space, either
a physical space or a conceptual space
within which you're doing this and that.
The, the reason that this upper bound
would be the length of time
you have before you need to refresh
the attractor is in retail speculative.
And the idea would be that
this would correspond to something like
these sharply of ripples
that you observe.
We don't know for sure.
It's a perfect lead into this
second question
and then have another comment
from Cambridge breaths.
So what you just said about ripples,
so they wrote,
Wonder if investigating
cortical traveling waves
via neural mass biophysical modeling
approaches, in particular,
the work of Wilson
can contribute to this work.
If yes,
how many? Thanks for elaborations.
Timmerman
in collaboration with Robin Card,
Harris has done
some really interesting work
along those lines.
I believe it was with Dante
looking at traveling waves.
I believe,
I believe in the alpha frequency
as evidence for the previous models.
And so the idea would be
that if you are actually relaxing
your belief landscape,
you might get a reduction
of like traveling waves of predictions
going down towards the periphery
and maybe greater inward going prediction
air waves.
And and so
some work
has been done along those lines already
by Timmerman and others.
That's really interesting.
And as I said before,
so although I'm like introducing
additional factors,
I do not think Rebus is wrong.
Just want to add
a couple additional details of like
some of the contributions
from modulations of cortical micro
circuitry be different.
You might be able to get
rebus effects from a variety of ways,
not just from this D synchronization,
but before I forget
earlier, you're some of free lunches.
Absolutely.
And I think this is part of like a is
let's say
I have a history
of crank it all to the max.
If each one is like has its own function,
you know,
it'll be depending on the nature
and both generally and locally.
So we've talked about dopamine too much.
Dopamine,
you might be impulsive too little.
You might not strike
while the iron is hot
and you might miss opportunities
too much.
One day or two little ones,
you might irritable and impulsive
too much
the opposite problems to a too much.
It could generate over time
a kind of psychotic
predisposition
that would be a loss of a free lunch.
The one more thing that you're mentioning
is, okay,
yeah, it's not just these two receptor
classes.
There's actually you a 14.
And so
one thing
I'm wondering though
is whether you get kind of like
this is potentially wishful thinking,
but potentially not.
You get the lion's
share by considering a couple in that
there might be like an order
in which they evolve and a ubiquity
where the ubiquity
would be one sign for like how important
it is to figure these things out.
So the just the broader
the distribution in theory,
the more you get from explaining the ones
with the broadest distribution
and so the one
and to have this extremely extensive
cortical and subcortical distribution.
But that's not necessarily
the case like you could have,
for instance,
a pivotal areas of the brainstem.
You're right on top of the core value
signals.
You know, one class of receptor there.
That could be the difference.
That makes all the difference.
Another aspect of
the hope that you can,
you know, make progress incrementally
with the goal ultimately,
you know, we're going to want
to get every single last one of these
receptor classes is that the other
the additional ones
might have a common organismic
cybernetic significance,
but they're different
because of their different locations.
And so that their functional account
might still correspond to, let's say,
overall levels of serotonin
overall levels
of some neural hormone or blood acidity
or some other homeostatic state
or state of challenge.
And so that the active inference
significance might be the same,
but you're tweaking differently
in different neural systems
so that the overall coordinate effect
is coherent
with respect to your expected for energy,
with respect
to realizing organismic value or
minimizing prediction error, with respect
to the prediction of you doing things
you need to do as a successful being.
And so one
more thing, though, is I'll throw off
the two key idea is
the potentially with these genes,
I don't know how far we can go with this,
but with this idea of like
so with a gene duplication event,
once you have two copies of the gene,
this allows you to basically
take one of the copies
because you've got a spare
and still do the same thing.
And now the other one can mutate
and can separately be optimized
by evolution
to take on a different function.
And so the idea is that
there might have been a common ancestor
that looks a little bit more one
like that at the extreme levels of it.
During this gene duplication event,
this became the two way receptor.
And maybe this goes
one step further to the to see.
I'm not sure,
but maybe we go a couple of steps further
with this kind of gene duplication story.
And what we're corresponding to
is peeling out
and separately module
in a modular fashion,
optimizing for particular regimes
of organismic significance
are going to be 14 to 17.
I've got to I don't think as I suspect
it's like maybe three
or four top stories of this kind
and that the other receptors, it's
these core 2 to 4 stories, probably three
maybe
being achieved
by having different functions locally,
but in a coordinated activity,
the same story globally
based.
There could be lower dimensional
manifolds that gives a lot of resilience
and also of of ability
for the system learning.
And one thing we've talked about before,
but it's interesting to think about
is in your presentation,
you did a really awesome
job of connecting
the general kind of dynamical systems
and inference questions
to specific human regions.
And then it's interesting to ask, okay,
well, insects
have a different brain layout.
They don't have the mental rhino.
So we can juxtapose
cognitive systems and learn a lot
about which attributes of the computation
are necessary and sufficient.
So I wanted to ask
which cognitive systems
you thought were interesting to study
in that sense.
I have an intuition in a hope
that may or may not pan out,
that the extent of convergence
is fairly substantial.
Now, things can,
I think, flip in all sorts of ways.
I wouldn't just assume this is correct,
but let's say
we're talking about an insect.
We would potentially
look to the central complex
and which has a lot of hippocampal
and to renal functions.
And so and it might actually be
an even better system to study
in terms of
you would have complete access
theoretically to the in
you would have a much richer access
to something like calcium imaging.
And so
that could be looking at something like
the attractor dynamics of like
and so there's, there's experiments
like let's say they take fruit flies,
they put them on
top of like a little Styrofoam ball
and hooked up to virtuality
and they have them
like doing different things.
You look at the central context
whilst doing that under different states
of Neuromodulation and we might see
common organismic significances
and a common computational account
in terms of the map
mapping space and policy selection.
Now, how far back does this go?
Some of this logic might even play out
at the level
of individual cells
and like either like for instance, like
one versus
2a1a0.
So low levels of serotonin
seem to have an effect of strengthening
cytoskeleton dynamics.
And so that would promote like an orgasm
kind of staying in place,
but high levels actually
destabilize the cytoskeleton.
And so they'll actually like
literally create plasticity and fluidity
of the morphology and allow the organism
to move around more.
And so some of these accounts
might go all the way back to the
like near the origins of life
and individual cells and metabolism.
How far we can go, I don't know.
And so some of these
might have even been repurposed for the
different social insects communicating,
although you could see these things
flipping because you know what goes on.
The individual
doesn't have to be the same.
In fact, because you have things in
one significance on the individual level,
that might mean
that has the opposite significance
at the group interactive level. So
but I think it'll be extremely rich to I
my kingdom for that science to be done.
Lou, do you want to ask a question?
I will jump in here.
Actually,
you know,
when we talk about the origin of life,
you mentioned earlier in your talk
that the third person perspective
is related to imagination and creativity.
And this goes back
to kind of what I was asking earlier,
but is it so much
that the third person perspective
is related to
this kind of like coming outside of ego
and looking at yourself, you know,
from this kind of meta perspective?
Or is it fundamentally
the dissolution of the self?
Like how much does an ant
think about themselves
or like a bacterial
that's part of a micro or a biofilm?
Like how much of, of that is imagination?
Like looking at themselves as part of
a whole or that's just like myself.
Doesn't matter.
I'm part of this bigger unit. Hmm. Hmm.
So, like, if you're
part of a well coordinated collective,
there's a sense with that,
within active of inference,
you will have converged on a shared
generative model for your coherence
and action that you're taking part in.
And so your role of what's being enacted,
there's a sense in which
it's not exactly like on some level,
in some way
there is information of some kind,
which is not necessarily egocentric.
In fact, it's like your role Alice
centric within the thing
that like even if
on some level it's like what you are
you as generative model
if you were to give the generative model
generative modeling process
as a whole perspective, it's not egoic,
it's not from the necessary
from a first person point of view either.
It's, it's from the coordination
manifold of,
of the group
that's doing this, this common thing.
Am I kind of getting it?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's
it's interesting.
Like developmentally,
if we were to kind of take when these
different perspectives of different kinds
come online, like for instance,
right out the gate, it's
not clear to me that we have like,
for instance, coherent egos.
Like it's not clear we attend to this
like right out the gate when we're born.
And so there's like a sense
like by default the,
you know, the infant might be ego this.
Right.
It's and by default
it's doing this more like an act
of coupling with its caregivers
and this sort of thing.
And it's not yet actually being enslaved
to an egocentric point of view.
There's kind of an interesting thing
with language for it's
actually like the ego itself seems like
when we use like in like psychodynamic
terms is actually
so when we say egocentric perspective,
it's like the eye is the first person.
But when you say like ego
as like a kind of like
extended unfolding of you
that's in the world
and all like your possessions
and your sense of yourself
within a social context
that actually is more third person.
So it's like ego introduced,
much perspectives more first person,
but ego as like psychodynamic concept
and the kind of thing
you might want to modify with
the psychedelic
is actually more of a third,
seems like a little bit more like a third
person fun kind of thing. But
and so then the
question would be the like
maybe there's like an implicit
alos centricity or non ego ignis
being enacted by any coupling.
And maybe that's like the primal,
like the primal, the primordial state
and then you, you attain
to an egocentric perspective,
but there seems like
there's like another kind of
more psychodynamic ego
or objectification of self.
The third person
of taking an explicit perspective,
they think it's, it's actually
first person
and that you're perceiving it from
a point of view, but it's fictitious.
You're taking the view on yourself
as if from without.
And that might come later in development
at some point, maybe through like
enactments of mirroring between
infants and caregivers
or between kind specifics.
But like if you're mirroring with others,
then you might establish
these cross mappings between what you do
and what someone else's does.
And this could potentially help you
to create representations that you can
then harness for viewing you
as if from the outside.
But when we're talking about
so when we say self and we say ego, like
what kind of ego? What kind of self?
But it seems like
there's a
primordial like minimal self
egocentricity of just seeing from,
from behind your eyes.
But then there's
more like a psychodynamic ego slash me,
which is involving the objectification
of you
adopting a perspective on you
imaginatively,
as if you were viewing yourself
from without,
and then contextualizing yourself
across space
and time and in different contexts,
different unfolding
as what you would need for something
like an autobiographical self,
something of that nature.
But so how does an app see it though?
Does an ant have like
is the first person gone?
Or like does is an ant entirely meta
all the time or a bacterium?
Is that like a total meta perspective?
And they don't have to go through this
like ridiculous, like self, like
whatever, creating a dissolving loop or.
Danniella no better than I would.
You have to ask the ants.
That's kind of the hard part,
but we can make one comment with
the difference between the egocentric
and then the more impartial
or autobiographical.
Reminded me a lot of the projective
consciousness model, projective
geometry model, which was also integrated
with higher order theories
and global workspace,
and a lot of those other topics with
Ryan Smith and Christopher White
and also the more geometrical work
with Woodruff and others,
because it's like we do need
both those modes.
We need the one where the hands are
bigger when they're closer to your face.
And we need the one where it's like
you're playing
the video game with a third person view.
And then it was really interesting
when you point to a lot of the
seen as deficits of memory
or cognition like false memory,
but just seeing them
as computational outcomes
of stochastic intercept
of lossy compression
and generalization, semantic encoding.
What's more likely,
who kind of person are you that's going
to, you know, scale whether you think
you did something or not?
So that's just such a interesting area
that you kind of took it down.
Thank you.
It's interesting bringing up like
Rudolph because like,
there's some things like I wonder, like,
you know, when you first
get the capacity for projective geometric
modeling of, all kinds and so like this.
So with and what's the nature
of the conjecture geometric model like,
is this something
that might show to establish or
is this something that you would expect
at the level
of like cortical micro circuitry,
like some interpretation of like
what cortical macro columns are doing?
Or is this something
that's actually more complex?
And it's like a distributed algorithm
like Hinton has like ideas, like Glom
the kind of get it
something like this like they
because what you have with this projected
geometric models the ability
to flexibly move between egocentric Alice
centric perspectives.
I can take your point of view or mine.
Once they raise everything
or boost it up into this,
I forget to do
that hyperbolic or for whatever
the space, as he puts it in from within.
There you can embed either
either want to move between them.
The thing I'm wondering
is like the nature of these, like
I just mentioned this like ability to
take fictitious points of view on you.
I'm wondering whether like the way in
which which is a lot more derived
and a kind of skill of moving between
things like the representations
you might have acquired through mirroring
with others and, and like to to take
another perspective rather than it being
something
that, that the visual system can just do
of moving between of automatically
translating from points of view
within this higher space,
like what is the nature of that model?
Like I've even wondered like,
for instance, is perception actually
always 2D and kind of like
holographic was always a 2D projection.
And when we talk about something
like depth,
it's actually either some sort of like
sense of
affordances or intercept of cross mapping
or the likely transitions between 2D
or even like 3D.
Like we, like we never like
Marcello's like 2.5 D vision.
Like, is that just the ability
to make sure that what's on the screen
that's 2D is always coherent
or that that you move between
as if you can move around a thing.
But we actually never perceive
anything in 3D in terms of our visual
spatial awareness of it
to loop around to the art,
I don't know.
But like you might distinguish,
for instance if you consider
the perspective of the art itself
as generative model,
then that might be by default,
more Alice centric,
especially because of its
like what it's specifically
doing to the its extent even makes sense
if it's it's fundamentally
part of the superorganism
the organism is it's
not even superorganism like like
like Daniel says,
like it is the unit that makes sense.
That's things.
This is the shared enactment.
But then if you go
maybe like the attractor dynamics
of like the central complex, this like
quasi hippocampal, quasi syllabic thing
that might be more egocentric.
And I don't think you're going to get.
Just totally agree with that.
I think it's a established fact
that the compass heading
or the polarization of light is processed
within one aspect head.
And then there are collective decisions
like the sex ratio of the larva
that they're going to keep or
the overall regulation of foraging that
wouldn't be expected
to have even a correlate necessarily
in the head
capsule of any single nest mate.
And so I think that's where
the discussion comes to like Multi-Scale
Systems, which is kind of a fun topic
because in Multiscale systems
we see sometimes a clean mechanistic
difference between the lateral
and the kind of vertical
or the nesting of systems.
So like communication,
we can see the interface
where you have
the lateral layer of individuals
and then where you have the layers
that are inside of the individual
it's a little harder to disentangle
if they're all like
kind of crossfire, but
what you want to discussion are the ones.
Yeah, I mean, it just makes me think of
how like, are we fundamentally broken
with our, like, self little egocentric
loop, right?
Like that.
Are we maybe like measuring forever
the incorrect scale of stuff?
Like, should we maybe be more concerned
about like the scale
of all of us together or the scale
of all of the parts that make up us?
Instead, we like kind of falsify and
create like our ego and our relationship.
We like project a lot
about how we think we should be
within the world
or how we think things are within us.
But like we don't
actually know anything about
I don't know, just related to that.
I'm in
stuff way beyond neuroscience,
but like I'd say
yes, but also
like I both think
this is one of the most valuable
and fraught parts of the psychedelic
and the
discourse around psychedelics
and meditation, where it's like
if you get this
myopic, egocentric perspective,
that's going to be a real problem
for multiple reasons.
It's even for you
it's going to be a problem
because you see things from one way
you're going to get
owned by yourself as a kind of like
you'll get trapped in all sorts of local.
You see things in one way
you really barely see in any anyway.
But I do worry a little bit though about
overly well,
you know, egos get themselves in trouble,
but like the ability to stitch together,
for instance,
you know, there is like a unit over which
you have potentially maximal purchase
and then like in terms of influence,
there's a sense in which
like you're the steward of that because
like the cause of closure is densest.
And there's also a sense
in which like, let's say
I want to coordinate
with others,
including myself, across time,
like the ability to like
have a narrative structure of the ability
that's going to be helpful
for not like just jumping at whatever
source of utility or,
or expected free energy comes along.
And so like to basically avoid being
functionally psychopathic,
like you kind of need the ego,
but you also need to have the ego
not be too tight
to avoid being functionally psychopathic
so as not to tighten that too loose.
Otherwise the whole thing's right.
That sounds narrative stick merging
like agent environment feedback loops
and also of the scripts research
that we've talked previously
with all the Russian and others
where that's sort of the top down prior.
So it's related to what you said
about the hard problem as to
if or why or why not.
There would be aware
ness of experience at,
for example, the bodily level versus the,
you know, tripartite zoom chat level.
But at the very least,
instrumentally, those top level scripts
are the narratives that decide like,
are we going to put everybody,
you know, through a tunnel
where only this exact width
is going to make it through?
Or is that a phenotype
that we have a lot of ambiguity
around using the Bayesian prior term? So
it is interesting
how and I almost want to ask you whether
you started with the more neurosis side
and found it broaching to these questions
or whether you started
maybe focused on other areas
and then saw the brains of specifics
as increasingly important.
Like there's so little separation for me
between like
the neuroscience obsession
and the existential,
like I'm constantly doing.
I'm constantly in a state of existential
freak out and neuroscience obsession
that I don't know which side,
which I don't know who's the dog,
who's the tail and who's wagging whom.
It's just constant existential crisis and
obsession.
So I don't know
what.
What would be
advice to somebody
who's curious about the field
or they want to be working
in an interesting area of neuroscience
and embodiment
and everything that you kind of mentioned
today.
It seems like if someone
wants to focus on psychedelics,
the best route is to cut your teeth
or to like basically get
a home outside of psychedelics,
establish a competency there,
and then try to bring that
within the psychedelic domain.
That seems like the best path that
most people who succeed
in this space take.
And yes, it's, you know, the standard,
fraught thing of academia
where it's like you're trying to
not be an inch wide and a mile deep
and you're trying to not be a jack
of all trades, master of none.
And where the perverse
incentives abound and
good luck, like
some combination of like
the both paying your dues
and not optimizing yourself
into a brittle straitjacket
where you can't see anything
past the next grant.
Yikes.
I feel you.
Okay.
Thanks for the answer.
So one small question from the chat
and then if anyone else has
any final questions.
So, Adam, thanks for your time
and the great presentation and cool work
and hanging out with us.
So Adam mentioned the DMT paper
with respect to the cortical traveling
waves.
The question was wonder
if there's any other work on non
alpha waves
and then just if you know about that
and then just a little more generally,
why do these traveling waves matter
or what matters
if they are important or not?
So there's a sense in which
like I
drew like those swaths,
those like synchronous complexes,
but those are necessarily
course screening.
You zoom in on them and it's like,
so what's the ontological status?
It has a certain relational realism
and that the extent it makes sense, like
draw that out, like the act of inference
in general with Markoff blankets,
it's like you can it's relative to what
other system that's engaging
and what types of inference they'll just
decide, like the scope of relevance.
I mean, there's additional like auto
poetics, self organizing moments of like
and then the internal.
But so like if you look though,
it's like a synchronous, like an alpha,
beta, alpha, you zoom
in, it's actually comprised
of these traveling waves
as more of a fine grained description,
although you zoom in on that,
that's actually prescreening
of population level activity.
And so it'll depend.
So there's going to be
potentially, if you're looking at
traveling cortical waves,
that might be useful.
So I focus a lot on like
the standing wave description
as like a joint belief over
whatever is in its scope.
But if you're talking about something
like predictive processing
within the model,
you might want to zoom in
on the standing wave
or the setting of description
for like the business end of passing
on your predictions,
then kicking up your prediction errors.
But depends like
it depends on the the, the,
the within the multi scale account.
What's of interest for the modeler?
One quick thing
from the side of the end of.
The wave question whether there's
any non alpha wave traveling wave papers.
I don't think so.
I think the one I think the terminal one
was focusing on Alpha.
If I'm remembering,
I could be misremembering I think.
But there are four psychedelics.
Uh, I think
Terry
Sinofsky I
think would be the person to look at for
some really good general
bio physics of traveling in the brain.
Uh, yeah.
Sinofsky,
I think, would be the place to look.
A quick aside on DMT, like I mentioned,
like there might be endogenous
EMT, there's debate over
how significant it is.
So some people say
it's not significant at all.
Some people say it's very significant.
So that's one place we know that it's
produced, is in the body,
the seat of the soul.
And it's
another place.
And there's some evidence,
but some people have questioned it
that it might be almost akin to like a
neurotransmitter system in its own right.
We just didn't know how to look at before
General
Organ at University of Michigan,
if you're interested
in that issue, in that debate.
But it's possible that like
one of
the main endogenous ligands,
we don't know
of the five actually to a system.
One of the main stimulus might not
actually be serotonin, but might be DMT.
So under like,
let's say like a limited experience like
so one, like I mentioned, like carbon
dioxide can do it
or maybe lactic acid
like you're, you're running for life or
for your lunch and it's super
high levels of blood acidity
and that might be activating
these proto psychedelic pathways.
But another one could be like
potentially DMT
used and things like
sex birthing and near-death experiences.
So like you almost bled out.
Maybe it's time to relax your beliefs.
You're about to bond
with another creature for years.
Maybe this is part of how you do it.
Whether bonding with a mate
or your offspring.
Very. SPECKHARD
These are early days in testing.
And also when we think about brain
and body, dopamine and serotonin,
other neurotransmitters
in, the blood in the blood vessels,
the immune system and then neuropeptides,
the whole continuum of short acting
neurotransmitters, slower
acting phenomena.
And then, oh, we're thinking about it
from a nested multi-scale systems
perspective with this kind of more local,
faster and then slower,
broader spatial
scales, which just has a lot of analogy
with everything
from governance
to the regulation of tissue.
So it's kind of an interesting idea
how a lot comes together there.
Also made me think of how
staring into someone else's eyes
for like a prolonged period of time
induces
like violent, disturbing hallucination,
which is like a put it in,
I don't know, some paper
I can't remember, but I'll look it up and
see if I can posted in the chat.
But it's interesting.
How like thinking through other's or
like looking through other's eyes
is, is so violently incorrect to us
that it's perceived
as like an altered perception.
I wonder if this is speaking to
like the way in which we bootstrap, like
objectified selfhood and me and like,
but because like, we do it so much,
this is like a core axis of imagination
and perception
that you can create
these weird feedback loops.
And I also wonder like how much
it varies across people like,
like, like if you were
like really far
on the autism spectrum like
or a far in a schizophrenia spectrum,
like would you like in a moment, like you
look at someone's eyes
and it's like it takes you
2 seconds to enter, like the psychedelic
or might it take like, you know, you
got to sit there for like an hour like.
This has this like, I think 10 minutes.
So I'll find it right now posted in the.
Chat happening to me right now. Yeah.
Well I am not your first active
livestream, not your last.
But thanks for joining and sharing
this cool work.
We hope to see you around the lab
and just in the area so.
Always a pleasure and an honor.
Talk to you later.
Talk to you later. Talk to you later.